i have finally caved and i bought my own  airpods max let me get into my  experience of these after owning them  for the first couple of weeks first of  all the sound quality is very very  impressive and it actually is better  than when i first heard them over a year  ago the new spatial audio feature works  incredibly well and it's just so  immersive it also works very very well  with the apple ecosystem the battery  life on these things is absolutely  insane the build quality is very very  solid the noise cancellation works  mind-blowingly well i'm very very  impressed with the airpods max but  unfortunately i think there's a chance  that i may have made a mistake by buying  them right now mark german mentioned  that we could actually be seeing a new  version of airpods max with new colors  later this year the new version of the  airpods max could switch to a usbc port  better battery life and high resolution  lossless apple music